GILBERT STRANG: OK?
I want to talk about a
slightly different way
to solve a linear
first-order equation.
And if you look at the
equation-- I'll do an example.
That's the best.
Do you notice what's different
from our favorite equation?
The change is 2t.
The interest rate a is
increasing with time,
changing with time.
So we still have a linear
equation, still just y.
But the coefficient is varying.
We have a variable
coefficient 2t.
And if we think here of
applications to economy,
to banks, that would
be rampant inflation,
the interest rate 2t climbing
and climbing forever.
But we want to see that
this is a class of equations
that we can solve.
OK.
And the new method is called
an integrating factor.
It's a magic factor that
makes the equation simple.
So that's another
nice way to solve
all the problems that
we've dealt with so far,
plus this new one.
So what is this factor?
Well, for this 2t
problem, the right factor
is e to the minus t squared.
And why is that
the right factor?
This is the factor
that I'm going
to multiply the equation
by and make it simple.
And the reason that's
the right choice
is that the derivative
of this-- you
remember how to take the
derivative by the chain rule?
The derivative will be
the same e to the minus t
squared, the same I, times the
derivative of the exponent.
And the derivative of
that exponent is minus 2t.
Minus t squared
becomes minus 2t.
So it's that little device that
gives us an integrating factor
that makes the equation simple.
And now I'm going to
look at the equation.
What I want to look at is
the derivative of I times y.
Instead of just
dy dt, let me look
at the derivative of I times y.
So I have a product here.
Got to use the product rule.
So that will be I-- so I dy dt.
OK.
dy dt is-- we can take dy
dt from the equation, I
times 2ty plus q of t.
And now I have to
add on dI dt y.
Good.
So it's the product rule--
I times the derivative of y
plus the derivative
of I times y.
But now look.
dI dt we know is minus 2tI.
So that dI dt, now I'm
using the key fact about I,
that that's minus 2tIy.
Look, minus 2tIy cancels 2tIy.
So I have a nice equation now.
The derivative of Iy is Iq.
I can just integrate both sides.
And that's the key.
That's the key.
If I integrate the
left-hand side--
so I'll just move
this up-- integrate
the derivative-- of course,
the integral of the derivative
is the function-- at time t, Iy
at time t minus Iy at time 0,
y of 0.
Because notice that
I at t equals 0-- can
I just mention
that-- I at 0 is 1.
When t is 0, I of e to
the 0 power, which is 1.
So that I of 0 is 1.
So that's the integral
of the derivative.
And on the right-hand side,
I have the integral from 0
to t of I times q.
So I'll put in-- yeah, e to
the minus s squared q of s ds.
I've introduced a
variable of integration
s going from 0 to t.
You remember this
type of formula?
The input is
continuous over time,
and I'm looking at the
resulting output at time t.
So all the inputs go in.
They're all multiplied
by some factor
and integrated gives the total
result from those inputs.
OK.
I'm almost here.
I just want to remember I
want to divide by I of t
so I have a formula for y.
OK.
So my formula for y.
When I divide by I of t--
don't forget what I of t is.
Let me put it again here.
Let me remind myself.
I of t is e to the
minus t squared.
That was the magic
integrating factor.
OK.
So I'm going to
divide by that, which
means I'll multiply
by e to the t squared.
So that will knock
out the I here.
I'll put this on the other
side of the equation, y of 0,
y of 0, and it will
be multiplied by the e
to the t squared.
And this thing will
be multiplied by e
to the t squared.
The integral from 0 to t
of e to the t squared minus
s squared q of s ds.
That's my answer.
Well, let's look at it.
I have y of t.
This is what comes
out of y of 0.
You see that the growth factor
has changed from our old e
to the at-- that was the
growth at constant rate,
interest rate a-- to
e to the t squared.
That's our growth from an
increasing interest rate.
And over here, I'm seeing
the result, the output,
from the input q, from all
the inputs between 0 and t.
Each input is multiplied
by now that factor
is the growth not from 0 to t.
This is the growth from 0 to t.
This is the growth from s to
t, because the input went in
at time s, and it had the
shorter time, t minus s,
to grow.
So that's the formula
for the answer.
If you give me any particular
q of s, I just do the integral,
and I find the solution to
the differential equation.
So that integrating factor
has made things work.
Maybe I should say what
the integrating factor
would be in general.
So let me take a moment to
see-- this was an example.
This was an example
with a of t equal to 2t.
What's the general
integrating factor?
So we always want the
integrating factor.
Our construction rule
is that it should
give us-- the derivative should
be minus a of t times I itself.
That's how we chose the
e to the minus t squared.
Then a of t was 2t.
Now I want to give
the general rule.
The general rule for
the integrating factor
is the solution
to that equation.
The solution to that
equation is giving us the e
to the t squared in the example.
This was the example.
But now I want a formula just
to close off the entire case
of varying interest rate.
I want to find the
solution to that equation.
And it is-- so here's
the integrating factor.
It's e to the minus
because of that minus sign.
Now I'm wanting a to come
down when I take a derivative.
So what I'll put up here,
the integral of a of t
dt, say, from 0 to t.
Now, let me just do again
this example just to see.
I have e to the minus
the integral of 2t,
which is e to minus t squared.
That's how I get t squared
as the right choice
for our example.
And the general rule is there.
That's the integrating factor.
And finally, finally, if
a is a constant, which
is the most common case--
the only case we've
had until this video--
if a is a constant,
then the integral of a from
0 to t is just a times t.
So number one example,
number zero example,
would be e to the minus at.
That would be the correct
integrating factor
if we had constant a.
And I'll create some
examples, some problems,
just to go through
the steps in that best
case of all with constant
integrating factor.
But now we can solve it with
a varying interest rate.
Good.
Thank you.